they don't get tired their hands don't
tremble and that patients make a faster
recovery robot surgeons are increasingly
used in NHS hospitals but the revolution
has only just begun is this a sort of
see-through vision robotic technology
but in future gives surgeons superhuman
powers
this probe being developed at Imperial
College London not only warns a brain
surgeon when they're pressing too hard
on delicate tissue but it also reveals
the structures that lie beneath using
scans taken before the operation if
you're closing in on this aneurysm you'd
really want to be aware of the forces
that are applied it's it's very easy to
to apply too much force and then
suddenly rupture it you're able to warn
the surgeon ahead of time to prevent
damage shrinking technology is allowing
scientists to make robotic tools too
small to see with the naked eye these
are less than half the width of a human
hair and dextrous enough to move a
microscopic ball it could one day be
possible to operate on individual cells
at the earliest stage of disease the
type of robot we are making actually
getting smaller and smaller can be
actually delivering the needle form so
therefore you that you don't need to
make incisions so they can actually
follow the curved anatomical pathways
reaching to the side I think about
flicking up lightly it opens like that
robotics of a different kind and for Dan
Melville it's life changing
so this is me trying to test out and see
how it goes the first time actually
testing it so by tensing his arm muscles
he can control his bionic digits
changing his grip to pick up different
objects it's sophisticated technology
but has been printed in just a few hours
sized to fit and in his choice of color
you can customize it you can change the
color so if I go one in black and orange
and red you could have whatever you want
and you would just and I personally
think it's a fantastic opportunity
that's just kind of show who you really
are in your arm so it makes it more
personalized for you as well
high end Bionic hands can cost up to
90,000 pounds beyond the reach of the
NHS but open bionics hopes to launch its
own version by the end of next
the price less than two thousand pounds
all of the grip patterns that the
advanced Bionic hands can do all of the
movements we are replicating and the
manufacturing techniques that they're
they're using is a very expensive
manufacturing process whereas we have
desktop 3d printers that just print
using plastic filaments I mean you
couldn't they're worlds apart the
manufacturing methods so that's how we
can be so they're cost
patients and surgeons enhanced by
robotic technology we're entering the
age of the cyborg Thomas More Sky News